Um,
welcome, uh, good afternoon. Welcome to this talk.
today we're here to speak about the
event driven architectures and the security,
basically about the event Bridge.
Um, let me make some
questions to start. Uh, how many of you are
you using today
event-driven architectures based on even
Bridge? OK,
not too much.
And the second one is, how many
of you are you thinking in deploying
the new business applications
based on EventBridge
and applying the
event-driven architectures?
OK.
OK, fine. So,
We're here to speak about security related
with event event driven architectures,
basically even bridge.
I'm, uh, Sergio Bilbao. I'm
working AWS professional
services as a senior cloud infrastructure
architect,
and today is with me here my
colleague Igor.
Hi, I'm Igor Rastolfo. I'm a
DOs architect. I'm
in a preserve, uh,
uh, AWS preserve in Italy.
OK,
so we're going to speak about
different
things. Uh,
the first one is an a short introduction
about what are the benefits of,
uh,
event driven architectures as synchronous architectures.
Then we're going to use an, uh,
history of a specific, uh,
company, fictional company called Nobel
and Mer.
To to show you
their journey from synchronous to
asynchronous and some security issues
and at the end we are going to say or to
share with you some takeaways and some recommendations
in terms of security for even Bridge.
OK, so
why are synchronous?
So a few years ago, I think too,
uh, Bernard Bogas during his, uh, key
talk
was speaking about asynchronous,
and he said something that is, uh, absolutely
true, and this is that, uh,
asynchronous is more similar to
how human beings are working in 90%
of our cases we are making something
if we don't have the response immediately.
We want to make something different and
we return. So
why not move or apply the same pattern
to our systems
to, to improve the systems. This is the
first one.
what are the benefits that we can have with a
synchronous? The first one is the
loss coupling when you are using an, uh,
a synchronous
or event driven architectures, uh,
you are the coupling the, the system,
the different models that you are using. So it
is going to provide you in the future some
benefits.
The second one is scalability,
uh, in terms of scalability using even bridge
or event driven architectures,
you don't need to take care about servers or
scaling groups or this kind of uh.
Uh, configuration. So if tomorrow
you have a peak in your business
that goes from 100 to 200,
you have it covered.
The first one is a synchronous processing.
Basically this is related with the
performance and with the
user experience. Using the synchronous
processing, the user experience is much better than
when you are using
synchronous in which, uh, if the user
is, for example,
requesting, uh, to create a report.
Um, and to make the report, you need
5 minutes. The user needs to be in front
of
the monitor for 5 minutes. So, using this kind
of, uh, things, uh,
the experience of the user are much better.
The fourth is even sourcing.
Uh, when you are using this, you don't
need to,
to ask, uh, the remote systems
what is the status
in the typical, uh, synchronous system.
To know what is happening on the other side, you
need to ask constantly. For example, with
a demon it's uh one minute,
which is your status, which is your status, and if
you don't have, for example, a response,
you can make something.
Here everything is based on, on events. So
if the other system has a specific problem
and writes an event, you can react in a
specific way or the way that you need to specific
events. And
another one is flexibility.
We're speaking basically that um
here, if tomorrow you need to
update your module.
You can move one,
put the new one,
and we work. You don't need to change
all the application in the typical
synchronous systems. Your problem is that
you have the same version of APIs
on both sides,
and usually when you are changing one of the APIs
on one side, you need also to change the rest of
the applications. So
in terms of, uh,
time to market for the applications or or new versions,
uh, it's it's worse than the
a synchronous.
OK. So, for today, we
have an example of a company called Novalamer.com.
Um, Novellammer.com is a company
that works in, uh, as an e-commerce. They
are selling, uh, luxury items.
They have a a standard system deployed
that uh at this moment is um
covering the requirements,
but the, the business has started to
grow up. They are starting to sell more and
more items
and they cannot uh afford all
the peaks of traffic and and bis
that they have, so
they are affecting their business. They are losing money at
the end. So they took the decision
to go from the current version
to a new version that is based on the
asynchronous using the uh MM bridge.
OK.
The evolution to the synchronous that they are going
to use is, uh,
first of all,
they have this um architecture.
It's clear that this is not a real architecture, OK?
It's for examples. In a real architecture
you have more components and more things, but
this is for example is,
is more than enough.
So the user is using navigator. With the navigator
you, for example, buying a specific item,
and internally you need to,
to call different, uh,
different,
uh, options that needs to be done. Like,
for example,
maybe the payment, uh, maybe
send a notification,
everything that you need in synchronous.
And they will move
to an asynchronous architecture
that is based on even Bridge. So in this architecture
they are going to use an APA gateway in
front for the for the request from the
user.
This APA gateway will create the
events that are required for the different, uh,
possibilities that you have
in the En Bridge. And using Ebn Bridge we
are going to route the, the events
to the different options that you need. For example, to slete
them, to remove from the warehouse
everything that you need,
OK. And now I'm going to
to give the control to to my colleague I
Igor,
uh, Igor that he's going to explain you
a little bit in advance all the code that
we have today,
uh, to execute everything and create the, the
company.
Yeah, so the
fictional project that we are, we are just
seeing, uh, the architecture is.
It's been created with the infrastructure code
and the Python for the lambdas.
So basically the project is,
is split into different modules so
that this release uh
the manageability of the, of the components
and the,
and the evolution.
Uh, so we have, uh, the bridge
that is the core component of the entire,
uh, synchronous application.
We have a producer that is uh
a lambda exposed by API gateway
that will put events
in the, into the even bridge
and uh.
Even bridge has a a rule
that intercepts events and then
send them
to an SQSQ
and the consumer
uh that is the other lambda that is uh
uh triggered every time uh a message
come to the SQSQ
uh so it consumes the messages and do
whatever the,
the lambda needs to do
to work on the order.
We have also a monitoring, monitoring dashboard
that we will see in a moment
that will uh show synthetic data
about uh the system
and
also a confi custom role
that we will see in the last part of the,
of the session.
Uh, the code is basically, as
I said, is basically infrastructure
is code for what concern, uh, the,
all the, the, the all the resources provisioned
and the split in modules
that are usable components
where you put all your configuration
logic
and deployments that they
use these modules to
uh create actual configurations
passing, uh,
uh, relevant information that uh.
Uh, you, you need to,
um, specify the context
uh of the application. So, this can be
used obviously for that
environment, uh, QA and prod.
Uh, the lambdas are in,
uh, in another folder in the source, and they,
uh, they are
checked out every time you publish
it with terraform and, uh,
they are written in Python.
Uh, there are
different versions we will see then what
it means.
And in the source we also have, uh,
some, uh, scripts, uh, AP scripts
that we use
to simulate, uh, traffic. So,
in this moment we have two.
Different, uh, uh, helpers
script that are running.
This one is the legit, uh,
legit, uh, uh,
uh, worker that is, uh,
sending, uh, orders basically
that are compliant with the,
with the structure that we want to use and
there is another helper that, but I don't want
to talk about it now but we
will see in a moment.
OK.
OK. So,
Thank you, Igor.
So, this is our situation
and yeah.
So makes the
first version of the application.
OK? Version 1.0
and they deploy it. And,
yeah. As always, it is the most secure
and incredible
application in the history of the new technologies, but
as you can imagine, no.
Always has problems,
um, so which is the first problem
they are starting to, to operate in
the production environment
and suddenly they see or they
receive a notification
from their internal business core uh
department
that they are seeing something that is
anomalous in a bridge.
OK, so
the first problem, and this is real when you are deploying
this kind of things is,
um. You are not making
things fine and you have problems. It's
the first version, so
sometimes happens when you are starting with a new
technology. So, what we're going to see
is um
how we can analyze it, how we can
follow the differences between the APAA
with what is happening inside the bridge to detect
which is the problem.
Why non-allowing producers can
write messages in the bus, which is the problem.
And finally, once we detect everything,
we're going to see if is the policy
is correct or not and if we need to,
to improve it to deploy something
that is more secure.
So my colleague Egor is going to show
you the code,
and. So,
bear with us if the, maybe the first
example will be very trivial and very,
let's say, stupid, but
it was just to showcase to anyone what, what
can be the problems, because
what we are saying now is
what we saw in some
engagement. So,
Maybe for all of you is
trivial, but
anyway, we'll see.
So now this is the, the,
the clouded console. So the first box
is showing how many messages
are arriving to the even bridge,
and this is, uh, the
number of invocation of the lambda
that will
put events in the even bridge,
uh, or you are already seeing that
there is a.
A great mismatch in the number of invocation
of this lambda and the number of
events coming here. So the problem is that
in our scenario, the only one that
is should
put events in the even bridge would be
the,
the lambda. So why we are seeing
this mismatch.
And you can also see that uh
uh those messages are arriving to,
to the other lambda
that is trying to manage those
events and some
of them are generating errors.
And they are going to the DLQQ.
And you can also see here from
the number of errors that are rising
up. So,
basically,
as I said, it's very trivial
configuration.
Uh, I just want to, mm I forgot
to say that uh the scenario
is supposed to work uh in a
multi-camp strategy.
So, basically,
maybe all of you or many of you
already know what this is a multi-camp strategy.
I just want to, uh, explain
a little. So, basically,
we as a best
practice. We advise to
uh create a different accounts for different
domains.
Uh, because this, uh, improve,
uh, uh, the reliability of, of
all systems.
It, it gives you the ability to,
um,
improve your security posture,
and it gives you also the possibility
to define different operating
model
for, uh, each of the components.
If, uh, for example, you have different
teams working to different components,
you don't want to mix
everything together in a single account and so.
The option is to use different
accounts. In this scenario,
uh, for example, the even bridge will be in a,
a separate account and also
the checkout lambda and the order
lambda are in two different
accounts as well.
And, uh, this is why I'm
saying this because you will see in a moment
what is the.
The very trivial problem.
Many, may,
maybe some of you can uh point out
what, what is the, the issue with this policy.
That this is something that we saw in
an engagement and
Can you say what is the problem?
Raise your voice, please.
Sorry?
Wild card that means that basically
anyone can put events in our even
read. So
as I said, it's very trivial but
anyway. Not, not
everyone is uh taking attention to
this. So, what we will do,
so the, the, the team, the, the,
the fictional team involved in the
checking out what, what was the problem,
uh.
They started making some, uh,
some, uh, checks on the policy,
and uh, OK, they found out that the policy
was totally broken.
And so, they decided to switch
to a new version of the,
of the policy.
And the policy,
uh, it stays with the, the
wild card, but we are adding a, a
very important condition that is
that we
are, uh, we, we want
that the account that connects to
the even bridge and put events is
part of the organization.
So this is the first, uh,
line of descent of defense, I would say,
but we will see that we can improve a
little more. But
for the moment this is the,
the way the team decided to, to fix the
issue. So
we just
change.
So, uh, I don't know if you are, uh,
familiar with terraform. Uh, this is the,
there is uh, the, the, the
resource policy attached to the even bus,
and we are just
including a new version of the, of the
policy
to in order to.
To update it.
OK, so now
we approve it.
OK,
now the policy, the policy
is updated.
And we can take a look at the
This, uh,
task that it was running in the ground
that it was sending random events
to the even Bridge,
at the moment is still able to
send because
the application of the resource policy
is asynchronous. It takes
some moment.
And then in a moment if
the demo time is not.
Is he? It will, it
will appear at the, uh, OK.
So, now,
we see that uh this uh
This worker that was putting
directly events uh with the AWS
uh SDK is not able to
do it anymore because the,
the account is not part of the organization and so
now it's failing.
OK,
thank you. So
he said
it seems something stupid, but in the 90%
of engagements that we're doing with customers,
the status is a standard pattern
for all configurations
for roles
for even bridge resource policy or whatever.
So this is the first thing that you need
to improve to avoid
external access
is the first line of defense that you
have to.
To avoid external people to write things
in the bus or read the things that
are written in the bus or these kind of things, OK?
So, nice. Now we have the version 2.0.
We are controlling the external axis.
But uh mm,
do you think it's enough?
I suppose that you say that, no.
It's clear.
So, now we are working
with the
application and again.
The business team called us and
said us that we are still
having anomaly messages
in the bus.
OK, so we need to analyze
what is happening now. I suppose that
everything is working as suspected.
We updated the policy.
We blocked the external, uh,
the external
producers, um.
What is happening now?
So let's see how we can secure
from different points, uh, internally.
So the first thing is that
we still have more messages than we have.
How we can analyze it or see it.
The second one is we're going to analyze
again the policy. Are we 100%
sure that the previous policy is
correct? Do you think that the previous policy
is correct? That the
the policy that we deployed in the previous step.
For sure, it's not correct.
Needs to be improved.
And the latest one is how to control
the access to the information. So
it was up to you. Let me change to the
to the demo.
OK. Still we have
more events than than expected.
So as you can imagine, the, the,
the policy that we wrote, uh, before,
yeah, it.
Uh, it, uh, restricted a little, uh,
the,
the, the, the surface attacker,
but basically, the, now we,
we, we just,
uh, trusted all, uh, all,
uh, accounts in our organization.
So what happened is in
this scenario is that, uh, another team,
uh, saw that the, the, the first team
was using the even bridge and so
they said, OK, it's fantastic. So we
want to use it as well.
So, uh, instead of trying to understand
how it works and whatever,
they just copy paste,
uh, the configuration and so it's
fine. We, we are sending events.
But anyway, the problem is that
those events are not for
the same domain and, uh,
again, it's not something that
you want to mix, uh,
different events and different type of
sources in the same even bridge.
So, basically,
we are,
uh, the team uh
was investigating and we, uh,
uh, they find out also another problem
in the configuration of the um bridge
that is basically the, the rule.
So here we have the rule that basically
gets
all the, the events
and forward them to the
SQSQ.
If we go to the event pattern,
OK, this is, again,
this, this is a very bad pattern,
I would say because it's basically sending
everything to.
Uh, to the queue,
so, but it's not
completely useless, this, this kind of pattern.
We, we can talk later.
I, we don't have now the, the demo,
but this is something, for example, that can be
used to store all the events
that pass in the event bridge for further analysis
to auditing purposes. So
it's not something that
is completely useless,
this kind of pattern, but
for our use case for sure, no, it's not the
best choice.
Because basically
external events are going to the to the
to the SQS and the lambda is called
for no reason for for events that
are not
uh
not the right. So what we can do
is to
again to
Improve
The, the policy
like this.
So instead of using uh
the principal wild card.
And uh and the condition on uh the
organization we demand that uh
uh the principal is uh uh a
specific IM role. In this case it will
be an IM role in another account,
but that's fine
for our purposes. And we are also putting
a uh an additional condition
on the content of the events itself. So
there is event source
and we want that, uh, the sources
like this e-commerce orders.
So there are lots of conditions
that are available for resource policy
for the bridge.
I suggest you to take a look at the documentation
if you haven't done before, and
they give you powerful option
to restrict uh the more possible
the, the access to the,
to the Hidden Bridge.
Depending also on the on the
content of the event itself.
And the other thing that we are fixing is
the rule itself because again this
was a very bad rule,
I would say.
And so, the event pattern
becomes something like this. And this, in this
case, we are, again, we are demanding
that the source is e-commerce orders
and that the detail type is
some something
among these three different uh
options. So,
basically, here we are also
enforcing a message
uh integrity, basically.
So now we,
we can apply
again our uh
I forgot to save the file.
It's very important to save the file, I
would say. OK,
now,
again. We should
see in a moment that the
The random event generator
is failing in a moment.
And now we are sure that we
are using the
correct pattern for the rule.
And we are also
Improving the security posture
of the of the even bridge
using a proper.
Permission,
sorry, I lost myself, OK.
OK,
and now you see that there is the.
No, it's not the right one.
Something serious is happening. What's
happening at the moment.
Demo time as always.
I see.
I forgot
to update the the policy, yeah,
the policy version
is still that's why.
I mean, It's in the takeaways
at the end, but uh I will accept it right now.
If you have very
strict uh security
requirements and you need to isolate all the
applications, always custom.
Uh, default bus, we only use it
for specific buses or applications
in which security is not a, let's say a
requirement.
I mean, imagine the typical example in which
you are going to write a specific blog
with no,
uh, sensitive information or with any
kind of information that is important.
You can use it.
But uh for the rest of our recommendation
in terms of security is custom
with very strict security requirements
to isolate all the applications, the buses, producers,
and consumers.
Yeah, let me add instead for
the application standpoint
that having just a bus for
all the messages of all the
application that.
In, uh, requires
more
effort in managing all
the events that, so
in the end, if you have,
I don't know, 10 applications that are
writing to the default bus and then you have
5, 10 rules,
you
must be very careful when you change
something in the rule because you can impact
some other flow. So
the ideal situation
is to have an even bus for
each uh domain.
For each, for each application domain because you,
you can manage uh easily,
uh, all the, all the events
that uh are going to the event bus.
And moreover, uh,
you can, uh, you can scale better
because you can, uh, you, you, when you
are adding new domains or new flows.
You're
Your point of intervention is, is small
and the blast radios if
something goes wrong is
just for that
specific, uh, workflow. Otherwise if you
are messing around with the,
the default even bridge and you do something,
uh, stupid, let's say you
can impact everything. So that's
why we suggest to use custom even
bridge us.
OK,
thank you for your question. It was a good one.
OK, OK, so now
just. To see, OK, the
event is stopped, OK,
so. Uh,
oh, sorry,
the PowerPoint.
OK, so now we are
controlling the external access. We
are controlling the internal access
only to the specific producers and
consumers that we need to allow the access
to the bus.
But the.
Seems that everything is working in the new version,
but do you think that we still
have problems or everything has solved?
Um, what do you think?
That can happens with the the current configuration
in which
we
we improve the policy we improve the
roles uh everything has been solved
there's still some specific uh issues
that can be.
Detected in in Urban Bridge.
OK.
Let me explain.
The next one is that
the problem with the message integrity.
Imagine this,
you have a bus.
I'm writing
events or messages,
but, uh, what happens, uh, maybe
one person is going to write a message in
which is going to use only,
for example, name and surname. Another one is
going to write something that is
import a number of items or these kind of
things. So
this is something that can cause a problem in terms
of security.
OK, so
we need also to manage the message integrity
using some specific, uh, even bridge,
uh, capabilities that we have.
So in this example what we're going to do is,
um, for the message activity,
why we have discarded messages when you
have, uh, problems with the standardization
of the messages, what you see is that
you are discarding a lot of messages.
Um, why are appealing messages
that aren't the standard
and how we can avoid it, which is
the, the most important part of all of this, so
it's all up to you, OK.
So, whenever you have a synchronous
application and you have maybe different teams,
the one that is producing an event, another
one that is consuming that event,
you need to find an agreement between
those two applications
because you want to,
to make sure that the events are in the
format that is expected to, to
be consumed and uh
and you want to make sure that uh
the data.
That is serialized in the event is
done de serialized correctly by by
the consumer.
And so, and you want to make
sure that the the two application
can evolve uh in parallel
uh using the same
schema event for the event, OK.
So, one option that we have is the schema registry
for, for even bridge.
So basically
you will see that there is uh
The AWS event scheme a registry that
uh uh
share all the events
that AWS
uh send to Eden Bridge for
uh for their own uh
services.
So if you want to integrate
to some of that of the services that is
sending
events, you can take advantage of the
of the schema to implement uh the bindings
for your applications.
But not only you can also publish
your own schemas.
So are you familiar with the
the Jason schema notation for
for event schemas
uh any of you is is using it.
OK.
So, basically, this is uh a
format that allows you to
express, to, to describe the
event in terms of uh number of
name of the fields, types. Uh
you can implement also some kind
of validation of the of
the
specific types that you have.
And this allows you to, again, to
Uh, publish an
information that is useful
not only for the for the consumer but
also for the producers. So basically what we do
is that we can, uh,
create those events,
making sure that those events are
completely,
uh,
compliant with the standard that is defined in
the, in the scheme.
Uh, what you are seeing now, this
schema, uh, is not
something that I wrote because I'm not
particularly
expert of those schemas,
but this, this has been, uh, uh, discovered
automatically by even Bridge. So,
uh an important and
I would say powerful option that you have is
that to, uh, start recording
events that flows into
the even Bridge
and then, uh, let, uh, the
system discover the, the.
Um, and the schema for you
based on, on the samples that uh
even Bridge is seeing.
So, basically, what you see, what
you see here, that the, these events are,
have been uh discovered automatically
by,
by the Bridge given the, the
events that I sent to the,
to the Bridge.
And these are the three types that we
saw before during uh
uh in the role, for example, so the
order canceled, the order created and the order
updated.
And the other important thing that that
you can do with this tool is that you can
download the code bindings.
So,
they are available for the major uh scripting
language or coding language.
And once you download them, you have
basically the, the,
the code binding that maps this
schema to
actual objects inside your uh your
uh runtime.
So you can get
uh fields from, from the,
from this object or you can set fields of on
this object
and automatically
um
the code also takes care of
uh uh validating the data
that you are putting in the,
in the field based on,
on the validation uh and
on the type that you that you put
here. So basically,
here we can see that we have uh.
The total amount, here is a number
in format double, so.
When you, when you create when you set uh
the, the total amount in your uh business logic,
you must, uh, the, the code and
then, sorry,
the class will, uh will give an error
if you are sending something that is not
uh uh compliant with
the, with the format.
And
so basically this allow
you to,
again, to have uh
a commonplace where producer and consumer
can share the schemas
and allows you to, to
be more self
uh so more independent in evolving
uh the schemas, for example, because you have versioning.
So, for example, maybe at some point,
uh, the order API will
Upgraded to a new version and they
are adding some field. OK,
so, and they will
maybe expose a new version, but
adding the, the old version still there
and you can, uh, by looking
up at the version of the event,
you can forward the request to
the API, the version 1
or or the API version 2.
And this also grants to
the producer to being
Uh, compatible with the, with the,
with the schema published for the version
that he is currently using.
OK, so,
um,
now we have an application in which uh
we are managing.
Properly external connectivity, internal
connectivity, and also
what are the messages that uh goes to the,
to the Bridge.
OK? But now,
The problem that uh usually we have
or we see
when we are working is that um you
deploy application
you solve the problems that you are finding,
but during the life cycle of application
you are going to make changes. Maybe you are going
to support the new version of R API
change specific module.
Maybe your company is going to deploy
a new, a new feature and you need to add something
new, which is fine.
Uh, and which is the problem.
The problem is that um a lot of
times with the box,
the developers are making changes.
You solve everything that we solved before.
And the developer comes today and
to deploy the new model.
He changes against everything, and you
are against in the first step or in the second
one or in the 3rd. So
for this kind of things is
we want to show you how we can see if we
did a good job
and what are the, the options that we
have, uh, to control this. For example,
how we can detect anomalies,
something that is important you can put it based
on some specific AWS technologies.
Specific rules to notify you
when something strange is happening
in your bus.
And the second one is that if someone
is changing policies or making a change, how
we can detect it and and
receive a notification or or see that,
for example, someone is changing the resource policy
attached to the.
To the En Bridge,
um,
up to you.
OK.
So, basically, what we can do
to implement this kind of uh
feature is a config. So, basically,
a config
is uh a, a service, very important
service in AWS that uh records
any uh resource
created or updated or deleted.
So you can track
the life cycle of the resource.
He, for example, you can see here
this resource.
Here you can see the configuration
of the, of the bus.
Uh you can see the configuration item
for the bus.
So basically, you are seeing all the
parameters that have been set to
create that bus.
Here you will also see, for example, the
policy. The
policy that we set before.
Now, I,
let's see if it works.
I, I restored the, the
first version, the very secure version of
the policy because I wanted,
OK, yeah, it works.
I wanted to showcase uh the
check. So, basically what we are doing
here, we have implemented uh a custom
rule. So
we have to, to be honest, two rules.
One is, uh, uh, an AWS
manage the rule.
So that is, uh, provided directly
by AWS and you can, uh,
OK, if you add a new rule, you have
a catalog of, uh, rules related
to the value services.
So for example, now if we go to
even bridge.
We can see that we have available
to.
Uh, two rules. One, that
detects if the
The even bridge doesn't have
a resource policy,
and the other one is for the schema registry.
Again, for, for having it with
a with a resource policy attached.
And we also created another
policy, a custom one.
That is
using a lambda to check
specific properties of the
even bridge. So
there is
a rule language
that you can use to implement
some checks directly without
having to code anything.
But for this specific use case,
the rule is not powerful enough
for to check what we want to
check. And so, we implemented
a, a custom script uh written
again in Python.
And uh what we want to do to
check is that uh
as we saw, we want that
the resource policy attached to the hidden bridge
as a rule
attached to it as a principle
and it must have also
a condition based on the event
source
regardless of the value we we want that
in any case the policy
put this kind of uh
of check in the in the policy.
And so we can take a look
briefly to the code.
So, the most part of this code is,
uh, let's say
for uh
implementing a proper rule uh
checker. The, what we want to
take a look at is the
Is this one,
OK, so basically we, once
we,
the rule is triggered every time the
resource is changed,
OK, and so what happens is that
uh the event of the change
is sent to the lambda and the lambda
does its job of, uh,
uh, getting the event and parsing it
and at some point it will forward
uh to this function.
That validates the policy compliance.
And so what it happens that uh it,
it fetches for the AWS
uh uh.
For the AWS uh um
principle and it checks if there is
a role in it and not and
not wildcard or something else.
It's
mandating that you use the
roll and then it checks
for
for the even sourcing the
conditions
in order to make sure that also this
uh. This requirement
is, uh, is met.
If everything is OK, it will
uh
give back to, to, to configure the the
answer that
the, the resource is compliant. Otherwise, it
will say, no, it's not compliant.
As you can see now, it's non-compliant
because I,
as I said, I
I restored the, the, the bad uh
policy version.
So now we
We can
update, uh, yeah, I don't know if we
will see
immediately because it takes a while because, uh,
basically it has.
As we always say, the, the word is asynchronous
and coffee is totally asynchronous,
so it takes
some moment, but in the end, you will
see that, uh,
the resource will be compliant again,
uh, upon, uh, these events of
non-compliance, you can attach obviously,
uh, SNS uh.
SMS events you can do
basically all the,
all the usual things that you
can do in these cases.
Uh,
OK, let's see if uh.
He treats us as compliant.
It it's, it's more
time. Yeah, it takes a while 22
or 3 minutes usually,
yeah, an important thing is that.
Even if you are not using uh
a
multi-count strategy, so everything is in
account and in that case,
the resource policy won't be
necessary to work because resource policy
is the only way
that you can use to
allow an external account to interact with your
resources.
But even if you are in a single account, we
advise to use resource policies.
This is a best practice.
So, there is this concept of defense
in death.
So, you want to add
more layer of security, even for the same
thing.
Because, I mean, if you have
extra layer of security, you are sure
that even uh if uh a layer
is broke,
for some reason you have something else that is
saving you.
OK, OK, let's see just
if, uh, it's now compliant.
No, no,
maybe at the end of the session 34 or
5 minutes. It's not, uh,
absolutely real time,
real time unfortunately, configure depending on
the rule, the change, uh,
sometimes it's 2 minutes, sometimes it's 5, but
it's more or less the time that he needs.
So, nice. What we saw,
it's uh
the most standard problems that we see
in terms of security with with all the customers.
It's true that uh when you start with uh
something that is new
you deploy it right click
it's working that's fine
no security
you start to work on top of that you
will start to to put security and
finally you will reach a position in which
you are applying the the proper security
to a bridge.
And this part at the end it's uh it's
important. A lot of time, uh, customers
are putting a lot of effort on
security, but they are not putting any
kind of effort in audit activities
to detect that the people with proper
accesses are making changes to the policies
and so on.
So, Uh,
based on our experience
working with customers and these
cases that we explained in
45 minutes, we cannot explain more,
OK? It's, it's difficult.
Um, these are the the takeaways
and recommendations that uh we provide to
you, OK?
The first is, uh, related with
organization level controls.
Apply SCPs
You know, SCPs is a very
powerful
preventive control to avoid
non-allowed security changes.
So for example,
If you are not using multi-account
buses with SEPs, you can block
it, so.
Take into account the CP is to provide security.
Then in terms of a general AWS,
if you are using AWS organizations
that we recommend, I suppose that you are
working in big companies and
you are not deploying standalone accounts, you are
using organizations.
It's important because it helps you
to control all the access
across accounts and also to standardize all
the security controls uh at the
organizational level.
OK.
Another one is at the account
level. I am permissions.
I know that I am is
more or less than 99% of the people
hates it.
It's I hate it and I'm working in security
in AWS. But
it's important,
especially
list uh least uh privileged approach.
I know that sometimes if you prefer to
put the organization ID and
everything can access to the resource, but uh if
you want to put the proper security in place.
You need to work properly with the with the IM
policy
and also the resource policy, not the
delegate everything in the IM only.
The second one is uh
resource policies.
Um, attached to En Bridge, basically
with resource policies you can manage
properly what are the sources that can send
events
to your Avon Bridge,
uh. You cannot
imagine the number of the times that we see
even bridges totally open
with no resource policy that any
resource of the organization can write
information or get information on the resource, so it's
a. I know that you
sometimes it is difficult and you need to speak with a
lot of different teams
to to get the requirements, but uh we strongly
recommend it.
Another one that uh.
With that that didn't speak here
is like
just BPC end points.
BPC endpoints is an AWS
technology that allows you to manage everything using
internally our backbone to
avoid external connectivity.
But uh the most important point of BPC
end points is that in BPCM points you
can also write.
I am policies.
That can control what are the clients
that can use the BPCN points
to access to the buses. So,
the recommendation is put BPCN points
and manage all the connectivity
through the BPCN points.
Another one is at service level
controls,
um,
as it will show you
specify the event patterns.
If you don't specify the event patterns
and maybe
the rule is going to be executed.
Making this kind of rules you can use it
to
to data lake
or this kind of thing so we don't recommend
it. I know in some
specific examples like I said that
you can need it to make a copy of the
events but uh we don't recommend it.
Schema validation.
It's it's important and this is something
that.
I've never seen a customers deployed.
It's absolutely true. No one is using it,
but we recommend it.
And rule auditing is something that is
a little bit external from
our technology, but it's good to
update the rules
and see if you are still using it or not
to delete or or maintain and also
the content of the rule.
Sometimes you have a rule in which, uh, you are reacting
to 6 specific
specific different events
and you are removing 3 in your new version
of the application.
We recommend to make this kind of audit activities
to, to analyze it.
Um, the detection strategies
clockwork metrics in the
1st and 2nd
examples,
uh, I already use clockwise metrics
to make a, a specific detection
comparing what are the number of events that
you are receiving in the APAgateway and
what are the number of events that you have
inside the
Devon Bridge. So it's, uh, it's important.
Clotrell you can deploy on top of a
clotrell a specific uh.
Uh, rules
that uh can detect
some specific actions that maybe
are not uh
standard that can be uh an initial
sign that uh you have a security incident.
Um, of course,
rules based on content and behavioral
analytics, uh,
you know your business, you know how your
application needs to,
to work.
So if you know it
deploy it on top of the application and we will
help you to detect the certain situations in advance.
Maybe it is, um,
the 90% of the times is not a
security incident, but, uh, in case of
a security incident you will, you will detect it
very fast. And
right now that's all that we, we are here
to explain to you. It's in, again in
45 minutes we cannot
explain too much.
Of course this is related with 7 Bridge
when you are speaking about a synchronous
architectures, of course you can put also
security
on the application.
For example, you can put digital signature
for the message,
um, to, to be digital design,
um, and other specific things that
you can use,
uh, from our side if you can still
learn and you can use a skills builder,
you know that in some cases, well, in
a lot of cases.
You have a skills builder,
free trainings and free labs that you can
use to to test and to learn
new things, um.
Hm. Um,
this is a specific one for security,
identity, and compliance.
Uh, we have everything split in different verticals,
so, and this kind of things like
even bridge and resource policies
are inside security identity
and compliance.
And
the latest thing is that uh unfortunately
we are still uploading the code to the
report. We cannot share with you the repository
to allow you to download the code
but uh you have here our contacts
uh heigor I'm Sergio.
This is our LinkedIn contact. So
if you have any doubt you, you want to
contact with uh with us, uh, or
anything that you need, uh, don't hesitate
to add us and,
and send us an email or what you want.
And
yeah, from our side it's it's all
so only to give you thanks for
coming here today.